♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
LOGAN ROY: Ah! Bon Dieu!
Nice, right?
Good for the morale.
How's your morale?
♪ (MUSIC STOPS) ♪
-Great.
-LOGAN: Good.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
JESSE ARMSTRONG: In 203, they go
on a hunting trip to Hungary.
The centerpiece of the episode
is this sort of
nightmarish dinner
that Logan hosts.
LOGAN: To our top team.
ARMSTRONG: I was lit-inspired
by reading about Stalin
would have these long dinner
drinking parties
where sometimes,
he would drink water
and get his commissars
and marshals
to drink alcohol and then,
he'd use their indiscretions
against them later.
-(TABLE GUESTS CLAMOR)
-Come on, everyone!
We're supposed to be having
a nice time. Drink!
It had a flavor
of those dinner parties
and the humiliations
he'd mete out.
-Tom!
-Yes?
Sit on the floor!
-Seriously?
-Yeah, it's a game.
-Boar on the floor.
-I really-- I feel--
LOGAN: Get down!
The actual boar on the floor
just came from thinking about
the context they were in
and the sort of thing
that might occur to him.
Oink for your sausages, piggy.
Oink, oink!
That feeling of a powerful man
unhinged.
Who spoke to Pencil?
Tom and Greg, a crucial moment
when Tom,
he maybe could
get some money in the bank
by selling him out, doesn't.
LOGAN: Hey! Crawl in a circle
and close your eyes.
-Greg, oink!
-(OINKING)
I don't think it's definitive
that it hasn't--
Tom hasn't changed
into a good guy.
It just seemed to us,
true people have different sides
to them,
and Tom, for whatever reason,
had enough regard for Greg
that he-- he didn't want to
do it in that moment.
-How was it?
-It was pretty, uh...
pretty tough.
Shiv and Tom, it's complicated.
How was your weekend?
-SHIV ROY: Me?
-Y-- yeah. Anything to report?
Uh... yeah.
He found out
on his wedding night
that she wasn't
really super keen
on a monogamous relationship
and that was tough.
-Do you wanna know?
-Maybe later.
ARMSTRONG: There is a bond
in that relationship,
I think, of like
sexual connection
and intellectual--
and they have a bunch
of different ways that
they do connect.
And so, it's not
a dead relationship,
even if it's
a quite troubled one.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪